[Music]
we'll turn our grief into action we have
to have action this includes allowing
well trained and certified school
personnel to carry concealed firearm
bump stocks we're writing that out I'm
writing that out myself I don't care if
Congress does it or not I'm writing it
out myself
don't worry about the NRA they're on our
side you guys have four you are so
afraid of the NRA there's nothing to be
afraid of we must pursue common-sense
measures that protect the constitutional
rights of law-abiding Americans while
keeping guns out of the hands of those
who pose a threat to themselves and to
others we're gonna have to start talking
about mental institutions because a lot
of the folks in this room closed their
mental institutions President Trump
talking with about 35 governors at the
White House today a big give-and-take
lasted some time in front of the cameras
as you can hear about school safety and
guns this has new polls out from USA
Today and Suffolk most recent saying
should schools be required to have metal
detectors at point of entry there you
see 62 27 armed police officer on site
and there you see that 58 percent when
it comes to curbing mass shootings which
is more important you see the breakdown
restricting access to guns and proven
mental health care both a lot of talking
about different possible solutions on
school safety let's bring in our panel
Steve Hays editor in chief for the
Weekly Standard Molly Hemingway senior
editor at the Federalist and Dan Balz
national political correspondent at the
Washington Post
Dan let me start with you you know
Congress is saying they're going to put
some kind of legislative package and
when you hear the president talking
about of all things the NRA and you
shouldn't be worried about it do you
think that there is a chance that some
something might come together I think
it's still going to be difficult I think
there's still miles apart on some of
these issues I think it will be a partly
determined by how much people try to do
if they can go leaner and simpler maybe
they can do to something on background
checks but beyond that I don't know what
they're going to be able to do these
standoffs have existed for a long time
the NRA has been very successful in
blocking efforts in the past after other
shootings I think a lot of it will have
to do
with what role the president chooses to
play and how effective he is apparently
he had lunch at the White House with
some NRA leadership including Wayne
LaPierre and others Molly I think it's
kind of interesting that we're even
talking about gun control is a response
to something where the more we learn
about it we're just learning about a
series of epic catastrophic government
failures at every level you know we've
heard about the FBI being notified about
this person the school failed the school
resource officer failed the Sheriff's
Department failed dozens of times being
told about this person and doing nothing
to something in one case the shooter
himself notified authorities that he was
a threat and nothing was done and the
idea that we would respond to this story
of epic government failure by
restricting law-abiding Americans right
to keep and bear arms something
protected in the Second Amendment is
very confusing to a lot of people and
particularly with the details of this
particular case you heard governor Scott
and the president talking about this
sheriff's deputy a couple of them
outside the school and also about the
warnings that were missed as Molly
mentioned it was the local sheriff's
department they've got to be completely
transparent we have to do a thorough
investigation and whoever didn't do
their job has to be held accountable I
got to watch some deputy sheriff's
performing this weekend they weren't
exactly Medal of Honor winners I could
only take responsibility for what I knew
about ie exercises might my due
diligence
I've given amazing leadership to this
agency and of course I won't resign
there are calls now including the
Florida House speaker for the Broward
County Sheriff to resigned what about
this Steve
well he has not in fact given amazing
leadership I would say he's been pretty
much the opposite of what you'd expect
of a leader at a time of crisis
responding to some of the things that
that Molly raised I mean there were
failures again and again and again and
not just in the last few minutes not
just in the heat of the moment but going
back months there were failures and I
think his department is responsible for
them one of the reasons that we're
talking about gun control in the
aftermath of this is because president
Trump is talking about gun control in
the aftermath of this and I think Dan is
exactly right
a lot of what happens from this point
forward will depend on how much
President Trump wants to expend
political capital to make something
happen now he said that he was
working on bump stock he doesn't care if
they do it legislatively he's happy to
do it administrative leave there are two
other places where he talked about
making some changes background checks is
the first one in the age to purchase on
long guns is the second the white house
seemed to in Sarah Sanders press
briefing today take a small step back
from that saying you know the president
while he may have said this it's is
still being discussed it's part of a
broader discussion on this does that
mean the White House is actually
stepping back from these proposals that
the president offered or are they just
actually making a tactical play to
include it in a broader set of
negotiation number of Governors stepped
up said that a couple of them said that
they didn't feel comfortable with the
teachers being armed including
Washington's governor in school now I
know that you have suggested arming our
teachers and I just no no it's not your
teachers not charming a small portion
that a very gun adept that truly know
how to handle so it would just be a very
small group of people that are very gun
adept I've listened to the first grade
teachers that don't want to be pistol
packin first grade teachers I've
listened to law enforcement who have
said they don't want to have to train
teachers as law enforcement agencies
which takes about six months so I just
suggest we need a little less tweeting
here a little more listening damn what
about this I mean there's a gaining
traction or taking away right I think
it's gonna be a state-by-state thing
there are a number of Governors I was
covering the governor's all weekend and
in talking to them there are a number of
Governors in both parties who are
uncomfortable with this idea but we
should point out some of them I'm
already doing it and we talked with with
Governor Abbott in Texas about what they
have done and I think there's they said
almost a fifth of the schools there have
people who are armed and this is
something that in part will have to do
with the culture of each of those states
the culture of the use of guns and how
comfortable people are with it but there
are a number of governors who say
including Republican governors adding
adding guns to this environment is not
what they want to see in schools but
we'll see how this debate goes forward
state-by-state yeah speaking of culture
I want to play one more soundbite this
is from Kentucky's governor
we have to talk about the culture in
this society and when we mock and
ridicule the very foundational
principles that this nation was built
upon where you treat people the way
you'd want to be treated where you
respect human life where you respect the
dignity of women and of children and a
people who we have been creasing ly
degraded in our society this culture of
death is becoming pervasive hard to
legislate something like that but he was
talking about using the bullet pulp
bully pulpits in all of these states
it's hard to legislate but it's so
important it's something that all
Americans can do is think about how they
are handling their own families what
they're doing to look out for their own
family members helping out people in
their community who have greater needs
whether they be mental health or
otherwise it's not an easy fix it's not
going to get headlines but it's actually
what this country needs